have you been by there okay alright
we've been up to what I mean this it's
been this has been having an opportunity
to chat with folks like you which has
been really cool have you been doing in
isolation what's going on where are you
I am right now I'm in the UK I'm at my
managers house actually I'm quarantined
at his house
just just do enough is doing man
everything's online
everything's on zoom so yeah man just
just still doing much doing the singing
stuff but just from home based you of
course I mean the last few years have
been wild for you what's it like to be
home and not travelling somewhere not
touring bro
it's it's weird today what that's weird
because right now I stood up poster be
on tour in Asia in America then Europe
Australia like like the hope will eat
for your world tour which is nice and
I'm going to see everything it's been
postponed
so yeah it's weird being a home I mean I
love being home but yeah it's just
supposed to be a waste seeing people and
do singing stuff and meeting fans but
it's cool it's been nice to relax a
little bit I've got my like a cup of tea
here so I'm better than fast as you can
say you've just been chilling right you
know what literally that's all of it
what I've been doing some of these
interviews have been what you've been
doing I'm like I've been killing
normally I'm like you know I've been
this I've just did this music video
Bernard to site yeah I'm chillin just
yeah Paulus I mean your fans even though
they can't see me in person they're
watching you online me because of you as
wild on tik-tok like it's crazy on tech
talk right mean yeah I mean people seem
to like the song which is cool and
people are very creative as well with
dances and tik-tok like a really
creative platform so the people that
follow me there like so talented so they
make the song even better by making
their videos so no it's really cool to
have people actually like support music
yeah and people are doing the dance that
you guys came out with how did that work
out who came up with that best
well it's normally me and then like
someone else on tik-tok because I'm not
best it tick-tock I'm kind of this
winging tick-tock so normally me and my
friends some of these friends I have
like the kings and queens tick tock so I
always ask them for help to make these
dances and me because of you I did that
with a girl called Holly H and she's
like a really big tick-tock were in the
UK and then I've just released another
song a couple days ago and I made a
dance up with some twins on tick tock at
do dancin as well and they helped me
make it as well and they're really cool
back with the shot between this but yeah
it was a it's been it's been cool making
dusters I'm just not very good at it
either
I don't see how you can say you're just
winging it I mean you've been doing it
for a few years and if they I mean
personal was way back and we're 2018
yeah 2018 class man you're so old you
know because if I'm honest it kind of
just happened on auntie talk you know
with like personal and some of the other
songs and I guess some people like kind
of really started from T talk so they
understand a lot more and they're like
really good at it and they've got like a
huge massive following I feel like I am
just I feel like I'm just yeah I am
winging it for me I'm trying my best
I enjoy it know which is a good thing
but there's definitely people that far
better than I am at it I get the feeling
that you're a guy that's totally up for
a challenge because like you're talking
about right now how you're not good at
dancing yet the video for a million ways
is based on dirty dancing I love a
challenge
I love doing stuff that's a little bit
my confidant but I also I do love
dancing even though I'm walking it I
loved us and the boys that are
passionate for it so the million ways
music video you know when we got taught
about the treatment for about the idea
of making like a Dirty Dancing kind of
dreaming I've never seen the movie
before so I watch it yeah I know right
most kind of young people I'm not saying
that another sell your own but I was out
Wow those young people haven't seen it
from honest unless their parents have
made me know I've shown it sure I love
me and it's pre iconic and I really
wanted to dance especially with that
that kind of dancing all the spinning
and always quite like sexy spy quarter
um you seem like you're having a good
time chillin like having your tea but
when this is all over like what's the
first thing you want to do like you have
any plans in your head for what you want
to do immediately when you solve that
yeah
okay so first thing I want to do is go
for a Nando's there's a place in the UK
called Nando's and it's like a chicken
restaurant we yeah yeah okay cool okay
well in the UK it's very special don't
know what it's like you know where you
guys are but I mean definitely here I'll
go see my my friends I miss my friends
and then go to the studio you know I've
been doing a lot of music from home I've
set up a little studio in the bedroom
that I'm staying in but I want to go
back into Helia I just want to go back
and make music and if it's been
postponed I have a lot of time to make
my own music so that's probably their
awesome well we'll be looking forward to
it man and you can work on your dance
moves while you're you know quarantining
as well there's no stopping you I
definitely meeting me I definitely do I
will be doing as well
yeah I'll be looking at yours this do
your I'll do here I've already got like
was I got a couple of things and cheers
me it's nice to G syllable with you
right